I'm Tory my name is Elaine I'm Lexie and
we are three best friends who grew up on
Whidbey Island I love when we all get
together because honestly it feels like
not a day has gone by like I mean we've
definitely changed a lot since high
school but we kind of revert back to
like our goofy younger selves and we're
together with the island is in
Washington State it's part of the
Pacific Northwest I always tell people
that it feels like something out of a
dream it really just always has that
hometown feel I love it I love going
into a store and like knowing half of
the people there you don't get that in
Los Angeles at all
so Lexie where's the first place we're
going today first stop today we're on
our way to deception path I always try
to describe how beautiful it is up here
to people who have never been but
there's just nothing like seeing it in
person yes
[Music]
I think the last time I was here hiking
was with you actually you took your dogs
and I brought my daughter this is one of
her favorite places in the world to come
because it's so different it's so fun
taking your kids like to places that you
and a kid it's like one of the best
things ever I think this is gonna be a
good one here it has been so great like
being with you girls again here
everything that I see here reminds me of
something some part of our childhood
sound like funny story about her oh that
was Elena nice first job I used to go
there all the time to get free mashed
potatoes alright guys so our next stop
is gonna be one of our favorite
restaurants Front Street Grill so let's
go get some lunch
what makes Frenchie grill special is how
close we are to the shellfish
we're right in pink oh you can walk
outside and see where your food is
coming from
[Music]
[Music]
lunch for us three usually it's just a
slapping I don't even think we eat a we
it's so pretty here like look at that
this is where we're from guys this is
amazing and even you can see Lexi's
house like I'll get there it's so pretty
in high school do you guys remember what
we were voted oh in the year buddy oh
man I was were good I was most out I got
most likely to be famous I'm still
working on that one mine was
embarrassing um head in the clouds
back here at still true very accurate
and built true so for our final stop
we're gonna try something new guys we're
gonna go to callaghan's firehouse studio
I'm so excited
[Music]
as a novice on experience we walk you
through the process of blowing out your
own tumbler full paperweight or face Oh
[Music]
Calahan himself actually walked us
through blowing the glass it was really
interesting cuz it looked like I was
gonna have like a cereal bowl and it
ended up be something like I could hang
up on the wall growing up here you kind
of think you've done it all but just
spending some time really taking in the
island and getting to you know explore a
little bit I discovered so many things I
think our friendship is really timeless
I mean no matter how much time has
passed since we've been here together it
literally feels like we're in high
school again it's like hanging out on
the island it's awesome
[Music]